si tu veux bien
alors
il fait partie vous savez en fait dans
un TEDx le chiffre magique c'est 12
conférenciers
quand c'est moi ça passe rapidement ce
que généralement au tennis Alsace on
commence à 14h on veut finir vers 18h
18h30 chiffre magique 12 personnes 12
conférenciers ça se passe très bien mais
en fait dans cette quête de de trouver
des modèles de d'un monde réenchantée en
fait je me suis rendu compte qu'il
fallait juste changer de regard que mon
fils n'avait pas raison que moi aussi je
n'avais pas les bons je ne posais pas le
bon regard sur le bon endroit le journal
de 20H n'était pas le bon lieu sur
lequel je devais
ma source d'information unique je devais
aussi voir d'autres personnes et
d'autres lieux et c'est là où j'ai
rencontré toutes ces personnes là et par
gourmandise et parce que je découvre de
belles belles personnes moi je me suis
dit non et bah j'ai invité des gens et
après je me suis rendu compte que on
était un petit peu beaucoup et après je
leur ai écoutez et certains qui
arrivaient je dirais après après le 1er
janvier j’écoutais on arrivera plus à
faire vraiment une conférence on va
faire quand même un entretien un petit
une petite interview parce que ce que
vous partagez ce que vous faites est
tellement génial qu'on peut pas le
laisser passer et c'est dans ce cadre là
que j'aimerais bien inviter au que j'ai
invité Jean-Marc alors Jean-Marc qui
es-tu
j'ai la chance je m'appelle Jean-Marc de
Balthazar et je suis né sous une sous
une bonne étoile puisque j'ai la chance
de d'avoir fait de ma passion une
activité ma passion pour la photo donc
ce que j'aime c'est photographier des
humains que ce soit dans un cadre privé
comme vous voyez sur l'image ici ou
alors pour des entreprises pour
lesquelles je réalise des campagnes
photos je crée également des objets
symboliques dans le cadre par exemple de
photos pour eux pour la marque employeur
ou pour de la cohésion d'équipe
ok alors et j'imagine que c'est pas que
pour ça que tu es là aujourd'hui quel
est quelle est la raison de ta présence
ici aujourd'hui je viens présenter mon
projet photo one pick for peace
et c'est ta question suivante comment
c'est arrivé en fait
je suis pas le c'est cette photo en fait
a déclenché le projet
voilà elle a été faite tout à fait par
hasard à Strasbourg et le lendemain où
j'ai fait cette photo en fait je me
réveille avec tout le projet dans la
tête le nom du projet one pick from
peace une image pour la paix une image
peut changer le monde et voilà donc j'ai
commencé à faire des photos et quelques
mois après j'ai décidé de dacter un
petit peu d'ancrer les choses dans la
matière et d'aller faire les photos à
Londres pour vraiment démarrer
officiellement le projet et par hasard
je me retrouve tout a été du hasard en
fait tout au long de ce projet je me
retrouve devant le musée de la paix je
fais quelques photos je me dis allez mec
c'est bon tu as fini ta mission et
quelques heures plus tard je me retrouve
devant la statue de Mandela ou là je dis
bon ok il faut que je fasse encore
quelques photos et sans rien calculer en
fait je me retrouve avec la guerre et la
paix voilà donc c'est ce que je croyais
qu'il fallait faire des des photos de
contraste entre guerres et paix et donc
ça c'est les c'est le mur de Berlin que
j'ai que j'ai vu en arrivant au musée de
la guerre et puis quelques photos que
j'ai fait donc j'ai fait mon pitch en
anglais voilà et j'ai trouvé quelques
touristes de passage là qui ont bien
voulu poser et voilà quand je me suis
retrouvé devant le portrait de Mandela
enfin la statue de Mandela
et ensuite c'est en 2017 en fait
un an après quasiment je me suis rendu
compte que c'était un projet pour la
paix intérieure que voilà c'était bien
de montrer les contrastes de guerre et
paix mais que c'était un projet pour la
paix intérieure et que la paix dans le
monde elle commence par la paix en soi
d'abord et
oups voilà donc j'ai continué à faire
des des photos après cette prise de
conscience
des milliers de photos puisque je dois
je devais être à 4000 à ce moment-là
donc dans les festivals au coin de la
rue dans dans des événements là c'est le
Samer vibration par exemple
à la bourse aux minéraux et ensuite
en 2020 il y a eu le il y a eu la crise
sanitaire c'était un petit peu au
ralenti et en c'est à ce moment là que
j'ai eu l'idée des portraits quantiques
donc c'est des c'est des photos que
j'imprime et ensuite je dessine la photo
pour lui donner encore plus de
rayonnement je vais ajouter des dessins
de de rosace de mandala voilà des formes
un peu comme ça des ailes de papillons
de libellule voilà pour augmenter la le
rayonnement en fait de vibration la
vibration voilà je vais dire long de
forme excusez-moi du terme pour ceux qui
comprennent mais voilà et voilà le genre
de photo que
voilà et donc vous rappelez le la
première photo du début en fait je sais
pas si vous aviez remarqué ce qui avait
écrit un changeur Life et en fait j'ai
pas compris tout de suite la portée de
ce message parce que c'était c'était
vraiment je pense un signe pour moi mais
je l'ai pas compris tout de suite en
fait que ben il fallait changer sa vie
quelque chose pour pour pouvoir
enchanter le monde il fallait changer
l'intérieur
être en paix à l'intérieur en fait ça
veut dire de s'aimer parce que j'ai
remarqué quand je fais des photos il y a
beaucoup de gens qui aiment pas être
pris en photo moi le premier c'est pour
ça que je suis derrière l'appareil et
donc au bout d'un moment j'ai remarqué
quand même que les gens étaient touchés
par leurs photos alors qu'ils voulaient
pas le faire au début et je me suis dit
ok tu es sur le bon chemin et finalement
le résumé de ce projet c'est ben s'aimer
soi-même pour être en paix à l'intérieur
et pour pouvoir rayonner cette à
l'extérieur donc la paix dans le monde
elle arrivera si vous vous aimez en fait
et et que vous êtes en paix avec
vous-même voilà vous allez le rayonner
tout naturellement sans même vouloir le
le faire comme ça consciemment en fait
avec le mental
voilà
et sinon qu'est-ce qu'on peut te
souhaiter pour l'avenir parce que je
voulais dire aussi c'est que ce que ce
que je fais ben ça m'est tombé dessus un
petit peu comme ça donc c'était aussi un
signe d'en faire quelque chose de des
fois vous avez des signes vous voyez pas
que c'en est donc faut arriver à être
ouvert et à se dire ok là le la vie me
pousse à faire quelque chose donc
faites-le parce que c'est un signe
certainement vous devez faire un truc et
tout le monde peut à son niveau
réenchanter le monde en fait chacun a
des talents pour peu qu'on veuille bien
être ouvert à la vie chacun a un talent
et chacun même quelqu'un qui raconte des
histoires à des enfants au square il
fait quelque chose d'important pour le
monde en fait voilà parfait qu'est-ce
qu'on peut te souhaiter qu'est-ce que
comment on peut t'aider dans tes projets
alors je vais je vais continuer à faire
des photos il y a plusieurs projets en
cours comment on peut m'aider déjà en
essayant d'aller liker un peu les la
page sur sur Instagram sur Facebook etc
au niveau entreprise on peut faire des
projets aussi si vous êtes entrepreneur
dans les entreprises on peut aussi
contribuer à la paix dans le monde on
peut faire des projets avec One pick for
Peace avec les avec les salariés les
collaborateurs etc donc il y a des
choses intéressantes à mettre en place
là voilà venez me rencontrer après pour
en parler
c'est ça on peut même prendre des photos
ce qu'ils veulent je pourrais prendre
une petite photo pour la paix on va
poser dans le Namasté et puis ben après
je suis ouvert à des mécénats des choses
comme ça si jamais pour faire avancer le
projet moi le but c'est de faire c'est
pas de me mettre en avant moi c'est de
faire avancer vraiment l'énergie de la
paix et de l'amour de soi et
un autre une autre chose concrète aussi
qu'on peut faire c'est que on a créé
avec une amie thérapeute des cercles
d'évolution mixte qu'on propose à des
gens pour retrouver la paix du cœur et
pour rayonner donc venez aussi m'en
parler si ça vous intéresse de
participer à ses cercles et ben voilà je
pense que j'ai
[Musique]
en tout cas
je vous dis je vous dis merci de de
votre écoute merci pour ce j'ai pas vu
si on a qui avait déjà posé pour ce
projet mais en tout cas si vous voulez
venir à la pause ou ce soir quand ça
sera fini le temps d'aller au resto ou
pendant le resto après lors du cocktail
n'hésitez pas à venir me parler et puis
à faire quelque chose à envisager des
projets excellents et alors pour
terminer ce qui me ferait vraiment
kiffer c'est que on puisse allumer un
peu dans la salle et qu'on fasse tous
vous vous lever on fait tous une photo
en Namasté et comme ça on me fait une
petite photo de famille
intime allez hop
merci beaucoup encore à tous
[Applaudissements]